[Music]
all right welcome to the Rubin report
I'm de Bruin and before I do anything
else make sure that you're subscribed to
our channel and be sure to click the
bell that's right over there somewhere
it's here in this area I think so that
you actually get notified as long as
we're going ahead and do in these videos
we're gonna talk about why I just said
that in just a sec today is our first
ever Sunday livestream you might even
call it a Sunday special but when a
Democratic presidential candidate says
they're in town and they want to swing
by you make it work
congressman Tulsi Gabbard welcome to the
right appreciate it thank you for making
it work it's great to be here yeah we've
been trying to make this happen we have
a lot I know you got a crazy day in
California so I'm gonna give you like
the most focused hour okay magical
you're ready to do it okay so we're
doing this on YouTube YouTube is owned
by Google you're suing Google yes what's
going on they've got too much power
they've got too much power I think the
the short story is after the first
debate as well as the second debate but
after the first debate I was the most
googled candidate of the night this is
what we were obviously hoping for as a
campaign had prepared in advance gotten
our Google ads ready and approved and
ready to rock and roll when all of a
sudden mysteriously right at the peak of
that time where people were paying
attention our account was was suspended
yeah so you couldn't roll ads could
people weren't seeing the ads that we
wanted them to see it was the bottom
line
we weren't really given any clear
explanations the answers we got were
very different from person to person to
person and then once that peak period
passed our account was magically
reinstated and to this day we still have
not gotten any kind of meaningful or
even an attempt to provide a
satisfactory explanation for it
which just points to the need for change
we filed this lawsuit not just because
of what happened there but because of
the kind of power that Google has is
this huge tech monopoly to interfere in
our public discourse interfere and what
people are seeing when they're going and
looking using their search engine and
really how they can impact
our fair elections yeah how do you
decide when that moment is that you want
government intervention because you know
I this is where I lean a little more
libertarian and I think people on both
sides of this can take totally moral
responsible well-thought-out positions
but there's like just that spot where
it's like okay now we have to make a
move yeah it's at that point where we
are now I think as a country where
people regardless of your political
ideologies or how you were using these
platforms are in a position where our
freedom of speech is threatened and you
have such a big tech monopoly with the
power to provide undue undue influence
both through their algorithms as well as
suppressing people's freedom of speech
and their accounts even as Google has
said themselves when they are in
compliance with their terms noose
agreements so even though you're a
congresswoman and Democratic
presidential candidate you've contacted
them and if you just heard nothing back
from them yeah I mean there was a we
should say that surprising there was a
huge delay and then when we got
responses again different response from
different people that obviously our
question was what happened how do we fix
it so we get our account back up plain
and simple yeah and that simple question
wasn't answered and so really our
lawsuit is is making that point that if
this can be done to me as a member of
Congress running for the highest office
in the land that means it can be done to
anyone running for any office anywhere
in the country it can be done to any
individual in this country what do you
think they're actually up to like do you
think that Google actually has a
political ideology or that they're
getting pressure from either other
candidates or the DNC which we know has
done some shady stuff and we're going to
talk about the debates and just to say
some of these things are listed in our
lawsuit of how in the past you've had
Google executives and people who are
very high up in their chain of command
[Music]
talking about how they can use Google to
impact or influence the election who
they want to win the election so you
know again this goes down to where do we
draw that line we have antitrust laws in
place
reason to protect consumers and that's
where I come from is we need to be able
to protect the rights and freedoms of
the American people and when you've got
an entity a private corporation that
becomes so powerful that they have that
ability to shift things or influence
things in their direction for whatever
their interests or goals are to the
detriment of the consumer I think that's
where government should have a role to
come in and again advocate for the
consumer so there's a pretty obvious
through line to Google potentially
censoring you or whatever it is that
they're doing and the real disconnect
that I see between the conversation
online and mainstream because if you
look at the online conversation I would
say you and Andrew yang are basically
sort of the two hot candidates and the
one the ones more than anything else
that libertarians kind of like you and
left these kind of like you and there's
this really interesting mix of things
going on but if you listen to the
mainstream you know well now you're not
in the in the latest debate so what do
you account for with that is that just
purely just tech that says this connect
is also what we're seeing with people on
the ground who are you know coming out
to campaign events town hall meetings
who are engaging in our process we're
seeing that same thing that you're
talking about online being reflected and
in real life where with a broad spectrum
of ideologies of people who are coming
to my campaign who are supporting my
candidacy because we're about unifying
the country because we love our country
yeah we have care for each other as
fellow Americans respect each other and
understand that by bringing our diverse
ideas together and standing united we
can do great things for our country it's
interesting that you just said we love
our country because I
I had Glenn back in here a couple days
ago and he said he didn't even know that
you were coming on because this has
happened the last day or so but what he
said was I disagree with Tulsi on almost
everything but it's very obvious that
she loves this country and I think one
of the things that's happening for sort
of mainstream liberals let's say not
progressive which sort of old-school
liberals and then pretty much everyone
on the right is there watching the
candidates the
McCrea candidates and there's this sense
that they don't really love the country
like they really think it's so
fundamentally broken or wrong or
historically awful or some version of
that but that doesn't come across with
you i unabashed my love for our country
it's what's motivated you know these
major decisions that I've made with what
I want to do with my life you know 9/11
was a pivotal moment for me I had
already just even when I was much
younger I decided that I wanted to
pursue a path of service somehow in my
life but it was it was that attack on
our country and our people on 9/11 that
really shifted the course of my life and
you know I chose to enlist in the Army
National Guard because of that because I
wanted to go after those terrorists who
had attacked us on that day and took
those thousands of lives something that
I and so many others in this country
continued to remember as we approach the
anniversary of 9/11 here in just a few
days so speaking of that so I wasn't
planning on going there but since we're
only four days away from the 9/11
anniversary would you ever imagine that
the sort of level of discourse and the
way that we seem to be fraying and that
the sides are you know running off in
different directions and the middle
keeps getting whittled away do you think
you could have envisioned that way back
when probably not you know especially
the unity that we saw in this country
after that attack took place it was a
beautiful thing and I think it really
represented what we're talking about
that as different as our ideas may be as
different as our backgrounds and stories
may be as diverse as our country is we
stand united as fellow Americans and we
are there for each other especially
during those darkest of moments but
increasingly we are seeing these divides
further tearing us apart as a people and
a loss of that remembrance of what that
unity is and why it's so important that
common ground that we stand on as fellow
Americans and how integral that is to
our identity how do you think we get
back to that because there's a feeling
that we should get
back to it yeah and kind of everyone's
kind of like oh I'm tired of the hate
I'm tired of you know destroying
everybody and the rest of it but no
one's sort of leading us there yet I
think that's the problem is is we have
people in positions of power and
influence and yes politicians people in
the mainstream media and others who
profit or benefit in some way shape or
form off of further deepening these
divides and Fanning those flames of hate
that really undermine who we are as a
country and I think I think the vast
majority of people in this country are
sick and tired of it they're sick and
tired of the gridlock in Congress
sick and tired of the hyper partisanship
and those the the divisive rhetoric that
so often comes out of Washington and are
looking for leadership that will bring
us together so does that sort of explain
a little bit of the media coverage
around you because I noticed after that
first debate when you were getting
googled and everybody was going well who
is this yeah is this but suddenly some
of the mainstream outlets so like
BuzzFeed and HuffPo and the rest of them
they were trying to link you to the all
right and the trolls and she's secretly
being supported by conservatives and all
that now being the people that are doing
the online thing it's like we see this
all the time and step out of anything
that sort of the the modern left doesn't
want you to do you're automatically the
bad guy but then when I saw it going
after you I was like yeah yeah I mean it
started before that to be honest it
started the very day that I announced my
candidacy for president yeah and it's an
anteater or which is your number one
piece as if that is conservative I mean
that's what they're trying to sell me
yeah which reporter asked me this
question literally just yesterday after
the New Hampshire Democratic convention
she said well you know you she's talking
about how I've made it a central focus
of my campaign that we need to end these
wasteful counterproductive wars worked
and this new cold war an arms race and
redirect our taxpayer dollars that we've
wasted for so long to the tune of six
trillion dollars since 9/11 alone
redirect those resources back here to
serve the needs of our people to take
of the urgent concerns people at whether
it's healthcare infrastructure education
and and her point was well this sounds
like a conservative message I said what
are you talking about right she said
well you know the conservative message
of how do you pay for things and I said
are you kidding me yeah I said I'll tell
you what Americans across this country
are sick and tired of hearing from
politicians and from their government
that there's not enough money to make
sure that kids in Flint kids in Newark
kids in communities across this country
can't have clean water to drink because
the government can't make sure that that
infrastructure ensures clean water you
know they're sick and tired of hearing
that
you know levees are failing and there's
massive flooding in rural Iowa that's
ruining farms for their entire year of
crops and they're told well you know
what sorry there's just not enough money
to make sure that this infrastructure is
holding to keep you and your family safe
so this is not a conservative concern
this is an American concern and it is a
call to action to to change our
priorities bring about this sea change
this is why I'm running for president
right to bring the the leadership and
the conviction to stand up to the
foreign policy establishment the
military-industrial complex bringing the
experience that I have both as a soldier
as well as in Congress to shift our
priorities to stop this waste and bring
it back to that central focus of serving
the American people yeah well it's just
such a fascinating flip ya suddenly
anti-war yeah they want to sell it as
conservative I most people are actually
anti-war I mean I think most people
don't really want to go door is that
being said is Trump complicating the
issue for you particularly a little bit
because Trump at least from where I'm
sitting has not been pro war you may not
be happy with some of the some of the
things he's doing but you know he wants
to get us out of Afghanistan it doesn't
seem like we're gonna be nation-building
so that being the anti-war candidate is
a little trickier as opposed to if it
was if he was just more of a traditional
Republican maybe we're right right I
don't I don't I don't think it makes it
tricky at all Trump campaigned a lot on
this
of ending stupid Wars bringing our
troops home calling out Saudi Arabia for
being you know one of the biggest
supporters for terrorism that they are
the problem is after he got into office
after he got elected he chose to
surround himself with the very same
neocon war hawks that have been pushing
for more of these counterproductive
regime change wars for a very long time
people like john bolton people he has
now secretary Mike Pompeo and I think if
we we find ourselves in the position
that we're in where in fact Trump hasn't
carried through on the promises that he
made the rhetoric that he was using
during that campaign and that's where I
find so many people were coming to our
town hall saying they feel betrayed
because of that because he has not only
not brought our troops home and yes he's
working on getting our troops home from
Afghanistan and that is good for America
I wish him success in doing that they
should have come home a long time ago
but we've got more troops in Syria he
and his administration has pushed us
very close to the brink of war with Iran
deploying more troops to Saudi Arabia
and to the region escalating tensions
there while even though he says on
television that he doesn't want to go to
war with Iran every one of his actions
has pushed us to that brink where we sit
today we're just a match could light the
whole thing on fire how do you balance
the rhetoric of saying I'm against war
without sort of tipping to the enemy
whoever it may be that you're not a
pushover that seems to be one of the
things that yeah because I don't I don't
say that I'm against I mean nobody wants
war trust me and as a veteran I've seen
the cost of war firsthand but I'm very
specific in saying we need to end these
wasteful regime-change wars we've got to
stop being the world's police trying to
go around the world and you know pick
off which dictators we don't like and
you know keep and prop up the
authoritarian dictators that that we do
like as we've seen happen throughout our
country's history and the wasteful
regime change wars maintain our national
security by having a ready and capable
military and continue to work to defeat
those who threaten the United States
continue to work to defeat terrorist
threats like al-qaeda and like Isis and
doing so in a smart and effective way
all right so I want to do a whole bunch
on on all the issues well just pop a
whole bag but I gotta just go backwards
a little bit here let's just talk about
what's generally happening with it with
the DNC because I think there's just a
belief out there whether for Democrats
Republicans it doesn't matter that the
DNC just strikes people as deeply
corrupt they they basically screwed over
Bernie last time there's a feeling now
that even with you not being in the
debate that it's just unclear which
polls are allowed to be looked at and
which aren't and how they you know
accumulate all of them and look at the
numbers and all that do you think the
DNC is actively working against you do
you think it is corrupt do you think it
is in bed with one of the other
candidates or several of the other
candidates what is happening what's
clear is that this system lacks
transparency the whole process is
lacking transparency and that's the
change and that's the reform that I'm
calling for from the DNC and this
because if they're not transparent with
their process and you pointed out some
of the issues that are coming to light
here is you know well these small number
of polls are qualifying these other ones
are not why is that who are they
actually talking to how many people are
they talking to there are credible
accurate polls that they're choosing not
to recognize and questionable polls that
they are so the the the problem with all
of this and I speak as a strong Democrat
is that it it creates a lack of trust in
democratic voters that the DNC is
actually working for their interest in
creating a very fair and transparent
process and when you've got a lack of
trust then you've got people who wonder
whether or not they should even be
involved at all whether or not they
should show up to the caucuses and the
primaries if the fix is already in yeah
and that that is sort of how it feels I
mean even this whole thing with
super-delegates that ultimately could
you know override what the what the
people voted for and the rest of it and
I don't know I know that there was a lot
of turnover from four years ago but I
don't know that they've done the
internal checks yeah you know there
there were a lot of people were
frustrated with what happened in 2016
who ran
for you know those delegate positions to
sit on the Rules Committee to try to
bring about some of these changes you
know I've been calling for an end to
super-delegates for a while now calling
for open primaries make it so that our
system in our primaries are open
transparent and actually representative
of the votes that people are casting
we're not anywhere close to where we
need to be they got rid of
super-delegates just in the first ballot
ad at the convention
but if there is a challenge ballot as
you know given a crowded primary there
there may likely be then in a second and
any ongoing ballots super-delegates will
come into play so right so ultimately
the super della delegates it still could
override the will of the which is the
whole problem with with that whole super
delegate system what do you make just
more broadly about just the general
process like when you're on stage and
you know you had that moment that really
caught fire when you were really taking
Kamala Harris to task on some of the
decisions she made related to criminal
justice reform and like that caught fire
and then it's like that you have to just
sort of do that that's a catch that I
think with these debates is it's it's
all about the media their ratings and
ultimately profits you know media's
money is that just us though like I
complain about the media you know but
you don't think it's just that all of us
sort of like yeah soundbite right but
but when you when you have the
candidates who are on the stage and
you're given anywhere from 30 to 60
seconds to make your case to the
American people
about any one of a number of really
important issues that we're facing our
voters really walking away with a good
sense of a depth of understanding on an
issue the clear contrast between the
positions that we hold you know they're
they're maybe let's say top ten things
you would do to reform immigration for
example you don't get to make those
points and make those differences when
you've got these quick little sound
bites and the only thing making news at
the end of it the only thing people are
promoting or remembering are those
flashpoints are those sound bites that
the media promotes and
and and no I don't think it's just us
because I've been hearing from folks who
were seeing out in the Labor Day parades
and people were saying you know gosh you
did great at the debate but I really
want to hear more hmm you know really
have an in-depth conversation with
candidates allow us to be able to make
make our case to share our experience
that positions we hold the vision that
we have for this country in a meaningful
way and voters aren't getting that and
and you know see some of them saying I'm
just I don't I don't have time for this
I don't get anything by spending two
hours watching that debate so that's the
somewhere right you don't feel more
educated right after and that's how
generally it's mainstream media has been
treating us also so these debates end up
being kind of Asherah
you know you're sure charade about this
is a providing a fair transparent
process for voters to become educated
but none of that's actually happening
yeah well I saw something that said that
you basically won the climate change
debate because you weren't in it but by
not being there yeah you know that that
oddly was enough do you think you'll be
able to get back in I mean do you think
you're gonna be able to make enough you
don't know I don't know we'll see
because it's not it's not about you know
are we going to be able to get to where
we need to in the polls there are 27
polls that are out credible polls that
show that I've met the standards set by
the DNC but they've just chosen not to
recognize most of them yeah what do you
make of a general state of where the
Democrats are right now where it seems
to me that they that Biden doesn't
really want to run that that's just my
feeling is that he didn't run when he
you know after Obama left and that they
sort of brought him in because I think
whoever the powers that be are they kind
of think well the progressives are
really taken over and if there's any
last chance for a more centrist
democratic party we've got to throw it
to this guy do you see that split in the
party that there's sort of like this
ever diminishing more old-school
Democrat or liberal verse the democratic
socialism no I wouldn't say that as it
relates to Biden I don't doubt that he
wants I don't doubt that he wants to do
this it's something that he's done
another three times before this is the
third or fourth time I think yeah this
at least is there yeah
so I don't I don't doubt his intentions
I think there's a bigger question here
about all of the different factions that
exist within the Democratic Party and I
think that a lot of the inward-facing
attacks from one section to the other
that we're seeing is not only it's not
good for the Democratic Party it's not
good for the country you know all of
these different labels and boxes whether
they are within the Democratic Party or
outside of it further divided us yeah
they further tell us and this is this is
one of the challenges that people in
Washington have had anything from the
very beginning is I don't fit cleanly in
any one of those categories or those
labels and they're scratched ahead like
well we can't figure her out right which
is incredible because it's very simple
it's how most of us are we look at
things look at issues like does this
make sense or does it not make sense but
for me it's it's I'm motivated not by an
interest to serve my party or to get
somewhere politically but I really
actually want to serve my country I
really want to serve the people of this
country I'm gonna do my best to do that
and that's how that's the lens through
which I view these different issues does
this action or policy in my view best
help people does it best help solve a
problem or is it something that's gonna
be harmful or cause further stress or
struggle or pain and suffering I'm
trying to remember in that first debate
did you speak Spanish I did not I did
not know okay so that to me was sort of
like the perfect example of I think you
know this about me like I mean identity
politics to me yeah I I truly believe
that it is the most dangerous force in
American politics today because it is
what will turn us it's the reverse of
what the American Dream was founded on
that we would look at each other by skin
color and gender and sexuality and all
those I agree with that and watching the
other candidates do it if you had done
it - I would he still be saying the same
thing it struck me as the worst sort of
pandering of like do these people not
speak English and if they don't speak
English perhaps we we should speak
English so that they learn English so
they can be more assimilated and
integrated and all of those things
and yet identity politics seems to have
completely taken over yeah there was a
woman we did a 4th of July parade a
bunch of them actually in New Hampshire
it was right after that first set of
debates and they're just it made an
impact on me there was a woman who was
sitting with her family and friends at
the end of one of the parades that we
stopped and we said hi and she was from
Central America and she made it a point
to pull me aside and she put her her
hands on my arm she was very serious and
she said whatever you do in a future
debate don't speak Spanish
she found that to be so patronizing and
and blatantly so and I think that the
identity politics that are being used
again to further divide us to further
drive separations between us and purely
for selfish political gain is a real
danger I agree with it undermines that
unity that we have that doesn't come
with groupthink or saying well hey we're
all exactly the same we think the same
way not at all yeah it's that unity that
we have in recognizing our diversity and
our strength and who we are as Americans
and the principles and and freedoms that
make up the bedrock of our country so
it's interesting that that's how you
ended that because I just I when I was
tweeting out that you were coming on i
retweeted one of your last tweets which
was you know like a 30-second clip are
you talking about freedom and liberty
and things like that I love all those
words but those words now have been
really associated with the right and not
with Democrats do you find it odd that I
mean right in there there's a giant
American flag and all of those things
that I've got the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence in there
like do you find it odd that it seems
that the Democrats aren't embracing
those things I'm so weird running from
them I'm disheartened by it because of
all of those who have sacrificed for our
freedoms just yesterday morning I went
back and read Abraham Lincoln's
Gettysburg Address again you know that
short I think it was less than two
minutes where he very powerfully laid
out how best we can honor those
who gave their lives on that battlefield
to birth a new nation based on those
principles of freedom and liberty and
equality and that we have a government
that is truly of by and for the people
and that's where as as some folks in the
media and others are saying oh well tell
us you didn't make it the debate
obviously are gonna drop out of the race
I'm not quitting I'm not dropping out of
this race because it is that same
inspiration that Abraham Lincoln spoke
of how we best honor those who
sacrificed all my brothers and sisters
in uniform who didn't come home with us
from Iraq that inspires me and motivates
me to continue forward in this campaign
because when it comes right down to it
it is the people in this country who
have the power to decide the election
and who have the power to make the kind
of change I believe we need to see all
right so on the libertarian side they
love you on on the war stuff yeah one of
the things I was getting a lot of tweets
today well you gotta ask her about guns
you gotta ask her about guns because the
general feeling you know they want their
guns basically so can you just sort of
lay out your position I think that I
stand up for second Amendment rights I
don't think it conflicts with the need I
feel we also need to have sensible gun
safety regulation I think that the fact
that we have not seen any kind of
legislation passed for a very long time
is because on one side you have people
who say there should be absolutely no
regulation whatsoever on guns and who
can own them and on the other side you
have folks who are saying that they want
to repeal the Second Amendment and they
want to get rid of guns completely and
take everyone's guns away and you have
those two extremes on both sides kind of
pointing their arrows at each other with
no real real substantive dialogue and
conversation happening with that entire
space in the middle where where we
recognize that there's no conflict
between upholding our Second Amendment
rights also making sure that these guns
are not put into the hands of the
who would seek to do incredible harm to
so what would be a sensible law that
isn't passed already because that it
always seems to come down to that
although yeah yeah I mean that's one
that that we just passed with some
bipartisan support from the house that's
sitting in the Senate now waiting for
movement you know I mean what would it
do it would strengthen background checks
yes or extend them yes and that's where
I think that was recently pointed out
the shooter in El Paso that if that law
had already been enacted that it was
likely that would have prevented him
from being able to purchase the guns
that he bought what would you say to the
people that would say well no matter how
many laws you put in place it's the bad
guys aren't the ones that follow the
laws and that we already have so many
guns out there that yeah you can pass
whatever you want you can say whatever
you want but actually bad guys don't
follow laws and they these things are
just gonna keep happening well I think
there's a few elements to this there is
some of these cases in these mass
shootings where they are going and
purchasing guns you know whether it's
from a dealer or a gun show or whatever
it is these are not people who are going
and you know buying a gun from the trunk
of a car so there's the issue of how we
can improve or strengthen our laws to
make sure that those loopholes are
closed but you're right there is a
problem with the guns and the kinds of
shootings that are happening every
single day in cities like Chicago you
know people families because Chicago has
some of the strictest gun yes no it is
it is and we've got to recognize that
you know I think that's unfortunate
sometimes that those who are calling for
gun safety reforms often turn a blind
eye to the reality of what's happening
to families everyday in cities like that
you know where kids are being shot on
their way to school there's incredible
violence that's happening in some of
these inner cities that we as a country
have to recognize this is a deeper this
is a deeper challenge that we have as a
country that goes beyond passage of
legislation that is one piece of it but
it is not the only thing that's going to
help make sure that we're protecting our
kids and we're protecting our loved ones
when you hear things like this
of San Francisco designating the NRA a
terrorists organization do you think
that's helping or or I don't think I
think that further deepens the divide
you know I I don't I don't support the
tactics that the NRA uses at all I think
that they are part of the problem not
part of the solution I think that what
we need as a country is for more
dialogue to happen between people who
feel like they sit on opposing sides of
this camp because they actually just
talk to each other I think most sensible
folks would be able to come together and
say you know when it comes right down to
it I think our goals and objectives are
probably closer together than we realize
well what's your general philosophy on
sort of usage of power because one of
the things I keep seeing and and this is
this has now gone on for years but the
every president uses more and more
executive actions and then what happens
is the next president just reverses them
the same pen yeah Kamala Harris I mean
every day she's tweeting another thing
about that my first you know they always
do everything on the table but you know
first day of office I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna take the
guns with all these things and it's like
even if you want to take all the guns
away you shouldn't want it to be done by
the president just signing a piece I
agree completely what's your general
philosophy on how much authority the
president should have and how you would
govern yeah I mean the Constitution
provides some very clear limitations on
what the responsibilities in role of the
executive branches and what the
responsibilities and role in Congress
has so you look at that as the framework
to be able to make those decisions but
you also look at what these people don't
care sorry to interrupt but do you think
in a weird way people have have sort of
made the presidency into such a king
like celebrity like role that they
actually in a weird way they almost want
the president to be able to do
everything or they don't even realize
that it's just a third of the government
right and until they want the president
be able to do everything until the
presidency falls into the hands of
somebody you disagree with and you're
like hold on a second what are you doing
you're abusing your power and that's the
hypocrisy that we're seeing right now
with some of my Delton fellow Democrats
are running for president there's
they're criticizing Trump for how he has
abused his executive power and his
executive authority and in my view in
many of those cases how it's turned out
badly and hurting people but then going
in and saying well you know what if I
were president
I was do XY and Z because you know in my
opinion this is what's gonna be good for
people you can't have it both ways it's
important at a practical level as well
because you see how Trump has gone in
and much of his executive authority or
the things that he's been pushing has
been to try to undo things that
President Obama has done now agree or
disagree wherever you fall on both sides
of that that creates a problem for the
American people it creates a problem for
our economy and business it creates a
problem when you have this uncertainty
it creates a problem with our foreign
policy where things can go quickly
shifting one way or the other where it
it ends up doing a disservice to the
people it's necessary to be able to do
to respect the responsibilities that
both branches the government have all
three branches the government has and to
be able to work in a bipartisan way to
pass legislation that will be lasting
rather than something that will quickly
be overturned or repealed as soon as the
hands of political power shift one way
or the other would you try to kick more
power back to the States because I think
that's one of the things that's been
lost we a literally don't talk about it
any yeah I mean we just talk about the
president coming in and this is what I'm
gonna do and yeah you know every state
will have Medicare or every state will
have this gun law yeah or anything else
I think it's an important I think it's
an important part of this is what we're
talking about the constitutional
authorities and making sure that at the
federal government the federal
government is providing those services
that the federal government is
responsible for but also looking at what
are the state's best equipped to do in
serving their people funding for
education I use that as an example right
now in New Hampshire's I just left there
I talked to a bunch of teachers we're
teaching special education and their
education is funded purely through real
property tax now in the wealthier
communities that's not a problem and
they have a plethora of funding to be
able to provide the service they need to
our kids but in the more rural
communities there are more people living
in poverty and they end up paying much
higher real property tax just to be able
to cover the basic needs for the
kids in their schools to me that's a big
problem their kids ultimately they're
not getting the resources that we need
so that's that's a role that I think the
federal government can come in and play
in making sure that our kids are getting
their resources so you wouldn't want the
government the federal government to run
to education every state per se but just
kind of fill the gaps right we're in
cases like that it's not right because
every states every States different you
know in in Hawaii for example providing
education to kids about Native Hawaiian
culture is something that's really
important to us that's something that's
important to our state but not going to
be important here in California they may
have something else that they would like
to do for kids in their state so you
know that it's it's always a balance I
think it's important to have this debate
in this conversation about the role of
the federal government and the state
government that you know again yeah we
see overreach happening too often with
that in mind are you worried that we
just never talked about cutting spending
anymore or certain yeah neither side
well the the Republicans talked about it
never do it the Democrats never even
talk about it anymore how would you deal
with that yeah because I don't believe
in tax issue I mean I've it's a spending
issue yeah III agree I mean this is why
ending the the wasteful war spending has
been such a central focus of my campaign
because unless we do that unless we deal
with the cost of war then we're not
going to have the resources that we need
to deal with all of these other things
it's not a situation of where you think
there's an endless amount of money and
we can sit here we can do anything we
can do everything there are limitations
people in this country work very hard
and they pay their taxes with the hope
diminishing hope these days but with the
hope that those tax dollars will be used
to serve them and the way that they're
intended what we see for so long now is
is just the opposite you see a lot of
waste and you see a lot of poor
decisions being made about how those
dollars are not going to serve the needs
of our people so one of the ones that I
thought would be interesting for us to
talk about is abortion because I think
you and I actually are evolving in
different ways oddly because you used to
be pro-life and now you're pro-choice
I've been pro-choice my whole life I
still AM but I always say I'm for
grudgingly pro-choice and part of it is
cause it seems to me that the Democrats
are going so crazy with pushing how much
later the abortion can be quite
literally now we have the phrase post
birth abortions and now you know you
only have to talk to one doctor and I
know and you know often they won't even
admit that a week before a nine month
pregnancy is coming to term that that's
still not a human I mean some really
really radical stuff yeah that that is
really making me challenge my own
beliefs but since you went the other way
on this how did you evolve on this
really just in understanding the role of
government and I take a more libertarian
position on this issue that government
really shouldn't be in that place of
dictating to a woman the choice that
that she should make I think that there
should be some restrictions though you
know for me personally it's I would not
make that choice for myself but I don't
believe that I should be telling anybody
else the kinds of decisions that they
should make for themselves or for their
family and therefore a woman should have
the right to choose and I will stand up
and fight to protect the right to do so
off point for that I think the third
trimester unless a woman's life or
severe health consequences is at risk
then there shouldn't be an abortion that
their trimester does that seem to be the
issue more than anything else that the
two sides just cannot get close on like
to me it seems because it's dealing with
I mean it's dealing with the most
existential questions that there are the
very nature of life and then it starts
getting into obviously religion birth
secularism and a whole bunch of other
things it seems to me the one where I
always say it's like just because you
think one way it doesn't automatically
mean everyone else is evil on the other
side or like that and you really have a
hard time doing this one with abortion I
think that that right there is is the
necessary kind of conversation to have
because it is it is the assumption right
that if you're not on my side on this
then you are evil right that somehow
Republican hate women and Democrats hate
babies right like exactly well that's
really not the case you know I disagree
with Hillary Clinton on a ton of things
but when she
came out and she said abortion should be
safe legal and rare that's something
that I agree with the the deeper
question of the philosophical questions
that you're talking about I think our
discussions that we need to have but
ultimately in my view the government
should not be the one dictating which
side of this whether you're you know
you're saying that you're taking away a
woman's right to choose or you are
mandating that they take another they
actually have an abortion I don't think
that that's a role government should
play and so what would you say to the
people that would say well wait a minute
the government's supposed to protect
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness what about the life of the
fetus you're just that you're just
having that superseded your having the
woman's rights to sue person a woman is
a woman is the one who's got to live
with whatever decision that she makes
and that's where I draw the line and say
that the government should not be in the
position of telling that woman what
choice she must make where you are in
reparations I supported the bill HR 40
that's in Congress a lot of people have
been talking about that really would
bring a discussion forward about our
country's past the injustice the
terrible injustice of slavery and what
impact that has had across generations I
think it's the right point to make in
how we move forward together in a
country to bring together a commission
of people so that we can have this
discussion as a country do you think I
see when I've heard Democrats talk about
it and you know they'll sort of come up
with numbers I had Mary Ann Williams
ended here and she sort of just
mentioned X billion I don't even
remember the number and it was just sort
of like oh you're just like it just
seems imaginary to me like so what are
you gonna say we're gonna give all
african-americans ten thousand dollars
or something and then are they gonna
sign a piece of paper and says we're
good to go or that or what would stop
the generations after them from saying
well grandma you you sold me out for ten
or a 50 grand I mean you don't pick a
number it almost seems sort of
antithetical to to human psychology or
so I think that's we're being arbitrary
about this does a disservice to the
whole objective of this legislation
itself the point of this is to bring to
light and bring to the fore
in our society today what happened in
the past and recognizing that it's not
all just sequestered in the past that
there have been generational impacts
based on the decisions made by other
people
previous to our time but we've got to
recognize what this is and what this
means as a country and have this
conversation not just in one small
subsection or another but have this
conversation together about how we move
forward and so I think it does harm to
that objective to kind of arbitrarily
point out well this or that or this is
going to be the way that we're going to
do it I think that in the meantime we
continue to work towards bettering the
quality of life of all Americans
recognizing there are people who are
really really struggling and suffering
in this country and not sitting around
and waiting for that Commission to be
able to tell us exactly how to do that
and for home yeah so we talked a little
bit about spending but on the tax side
now what's your general philosophy on
taxes how do you decide who you can
attacks how much you're gonna tax them
who you're gonna give it to yeah I mean
it's it's got to be fair and this is
something we'll be releasing later on
through the course of our campaign as
far as a detailed tax plan but we know
one thing that the tax system we have
right now the tax code that we have is
not fair it's not fair and it's hurting
the people who are struggling the most
and benefiting the very few who are
living the most comfortable comfortably
and who frankly don't need the help you
know we often talk about the Amazon
example of how now not just for this
year but for previous years they've
gotten by with paying no taxes and
actually getting a pretty sizable
business yeah paying taxes that happens
that does seem wrong to me exactly yeah
exactly and others will say well you
know it's legal but that's the whole
point the fact that they have tax
loopholes serious tax loopholes that
they can exploit that have put them in
this position while you as a small
business owner and many others across
the country have no tax loophole that
you can exploit to get the same good
deal that they got points to the heart
of the problem and this is where I talk
about everywhere I go
one glaring example of what happens
you've got a government of the rich and
powerful rather than a government of by
and for the people
so the the reform we need to bring about
to our tax code has to be a fair one
that does level the playing field and
makes it so that we are not benefiting
the very few at the expense of everybody
else so one of the things I noticed you
know I was on tour with Jordan Peterson
for most the last year and I went to
Hawaii literally for the gig and I was
like I want to see ecology but it didn't
work out and flew back that same night
but one of the things that I notice just
from from an outsider going to a hundred
some-odd cities in the United States was
that where the publicans were in control
the cities this is just what I saw was
that the cities seemed cleaner and you
know Salt Lake City and Dallas all of
those sort of more republican-leaning
cities and the places that seemed the
worst San Francisco I mean a lot of the
cities here in California even just
where I live now in Los Angeles the
homelessness is way up all of these
things and I think people are starting
to pick up on this that that there's a
certain rhetoric like well we should
give more to poor people which I think
most people in their hearts want to do
but that it doesn't necessarily work so
how do you make sure that if you want to
tax certain people who are doing well to
help other people how do you make sure
it actually works and it's not just this
thing that you're saying because you
kind of feel good you know it feels good
we're gonna help poor people that that
feels good but how do you make sure that
it actually works cuz I didn't really
see that yeah when I when I went to all
these different I'll challenge the
premise that you're laying out for a
minute because the homeless crisis you
brought up it I mean this is a homeless
crisis that that is impacting our whole
country and on the Financial Services
Committee that I sit on we have
jurisdiction over HUD and therefore
affordable housing and we've had some
pretty impactful hearings focused on how
we deal with this affordable housing
crisis and there are Republicans who are
just as passionate about how we do this
and the need for it as there are
Democrats I think recognizing that this
isn't just an issue affecting blue
states this is an issue that's affecting
the country and we've got to come
together to resolve it the debate is
about how how best do we do that some
say that there should be only federal
federally funded
housing projects that are truly
affordable for example versus
public-private partnerships that bring
together say you know if we can get a
government lease for a dollar a year on
a plot of land make a deal with the
county and you can bring in a private
developer to do it at a cheaper price so
that that that cheaper price is passed
on to the consumer these are the kinds
of conversations I like that we're
having yeah that's where I can go okay
well then we can get right and that that
that gets to the point of which I think
is an important one is it's not about if
we're helping people who are poor or in
poverty it's about making sure that what
we are doing is actually helping and I
think that's really important it's both
important from a fiscal responsibility
perspective really most importantly if
we are sincere about wanting to help
people let's actually make sure that
they're able to be helped in the way
that they need it most is the problem
though that they that often when we're
helping people were actually just
trapping them because they're how do you
mean well that they get an affordable
housing and then it's like all right
well now I'm paying say 300 dollars to
be in an apartment in a decent area and
then if you look and you go well wait a
minute now if I get a better job and I'm
making more which gives me dignity and
respect and all those things well I'm
gonna lose the affordable housing and
now I'm gonna need a second job just to
move out I mean we see this yeah I lived
in New York City my whole life where
there half these buildings were rent
stabilized versus market value and then
you'd see quite literally families that
were there for generations and it was
like why would you go anywhere yeah you
know that that's that is a problem that
I think needs to be fixed where there is
no bridge I someone came to a town hall
meeting the other day and raised this
issue about Medicaid that a family who
had qualified for Medicaid because of
the income level that they had felt
trapped because if they started to do
well and make a little bit more they
were fearful that they would lose their
health coverage and then they wouldn't
be able to get the medicine that they
need it was the catch-22 so I think that
generally while they're always
unfortunately some that abuse the system
I think generally people want to do well
for themselves and their families they
want to be able to continue to grow and
and improve their own quality of life I
think there are these
problems within our system that creates
this catch-22 where they're either
comfortable in the situation that
they're in but if they start to do just
a little bit better than they risk
losing their house they risk losing
their healthcare they risk losing that
security that they need for their
families where if we did make it
incremental or provide this bridge that
doesn't just say well you either got
help or you're you're out on the street
on your own I think there's a practical
way to solve this yeah so so we'll just
do one or two more big issues there then
we'll do some silly or fun yeah fun
stuff how about that so immigration I
think there's a general sense that the
the candidates the Democrats are
basically trying to outdo each other for
open borders something like that a do
you think that's a fair way to start the
question and B where they sit on that I
don't I don't support open borders
without secure borders we don't really
have a country and while some of the
other Democratic candidates will say
well open borders that's a conservative
argument and that's not really what's
being advocated for if you look at the
practical implications if some of the
things are pushing for it is essentially
open borders I think there's a few
things that we've got to do and we're
talking about immigration reform one is
we've got to have secure borders this is
not Trump's wall from sea to shining sea
it's about seeing again what makes sense
you know I look at things from a
practical objective oriented standpoint
I'm a soldier so I look at what's our
objective secure the borders in some
places it may make the most sense to
have a wall or some kind of physical
barrier in place and other places it
won't make sense so you use technology
and use all the other tools that we have
ultimately to accomplish that objective
of security at the way let me plus you
there so is the problem though just from
that starting point that seems so
obvious I think the average person
watching this is going of course
countries exist because there are
borders now but even that starting point
you're gonna get people that are further
to left are you going well there's some
level of racism or xenophobia there or I
mean that's what you there's always that
subtext to this conversation which is I
think it's a big problem because it
takes away from again be very clear-eyed
and pragmatic and practical about this
if you want to advocate for open borders
that's fine
stand on that platform make that
argument and have your facts and your
evidence to back it up I don't believe
that's smart I think that our country
needs secure borders just like we need
to reform our completely broken
immigration system our legal immigration
system is not working for anybody it's
not working for our economy it's not
working for our businesses it's not
working for our farmers it's not working
for our families and our broken legal
immigration system is only worsening the
problems that we're having with people
who are then coming to this country
whether it be on tourist visas or other
visas and then over staying or you have
people who are trying to come into our
country between ports of entry for those
who are seeking asylum in our country
we're seeing so much of what's happening
at the border because of a severe lack
of resources going towards those judges
and administrators who are there to
adjudicate and take these cases and make
their assessments and make those
decisions so I think broadly those are
the three things that right away we need
to work towards doing and I think if we
did so if you take away all the
political noise and the rhetoric and the
flame-throwing
I think we'd actually be able to get
legislation passed we'd actually be able
to solve some of these problems is this
one of those weird ones where it's sort
of what you said before about how when
you're in power you act one way and
we're not in power yet another way like
almost putting aside the strange way
that Trump speaks the things that he
says about the border actually you can
find videos of Obama and Hillary Clinton
and Chuck Schumer saying almost the
exact same thing and then everyone just
takes the opposite position because now
they're the ones in opposition I think
that's that this is the epitome of the
hyper partisanship and why there's
gridlock in Washington and it's
something that when I first got elected
to Congress in 2012 we had 84 of us who
were elected in that year there were I
think 50 Democrats and 34 Republicans
for a couple of days we all went to
Washington we're getting oriented around
the place and and we spent a lot of time
together and then all of a sudden it was
like a flip switched and the Democrats
went one way the Republicans went the
other way and everything was separate
after that and we were told some of the
same things which was all right look
you're gonna here's the Democratic
agenda you know you're not gonna work
with Republicans and especially these
ones who are in these districts that we
want to beat because you might make them
look good and so on and so on we don't
want that to happen and my Republican
friends tell me they were told basically
the same thing pointing to hey
regardless to things regardless of
whether the substance of a bill is good
if it's got the other guy's letter next
to the bill or the next to the name you
shouldn't vote for it but if we
reintroduce the same idea or the same
bill and it's our guy or our gal then
yeah by all means go and champion that
forward and I think this is exactly the
problem and this is I mean I'm
frustrated this this is what the
American people are so frustrated with
is they're like screaming and yelling
from the sidelines saying hey what about
us in all of this you have to hugely
powerful political parties more
interested in battling each other and
seeing how many wins they can get in
their column so they can win the next
election at the expense of the
well-being of our people that is the
biggest problem here yeah this is total
non sequitur but it just reminded me
that right when I tweet it out that you
were coming on that a whole bunch of
people wanted me to ask you about Syria
because you'd said you would you would
talk to Assad what you you've taught who
you have talked to aside yeah you did
talk that okay so I think a lot of
people then think okay now she's
supporting Assad and the support
anything she's doing and then he's crate
you know then you get the articles oh
she's a Russian you know all that all
that nonsense let's put all that stuff
aside for a second how do you balance
the ability to build the build bridges
wherever you want to build them versus
empowering somebody that is actually
truly dangerous there's one thing I know
very clearly and deeply that the only
alternative to diplomacy is war so we
got to have the courage to have those
conversations to have those meetings in
the interests of pursuing peace and
strengthening our national security and
I'd be willing to meet with brutal
dictators adversaries whomever I would
need to meet
if it meant there was a possibility of
preventing more of my brothers and
sisters in uniform from being sent to
fight in a war that had nothing to do
with our national security that had
nothing to do with furthering the
interests of the American people so it's
a risk you just have to take you think
ultimately to just it's a it's a
political risk but this is the problem
we've got to be able to put the
well-being of our people ahead of
politics you know I didn't make that
decision because I thought oh this is
gonna be great for my re-election
campaign not at all
I went and I had that meeting and for
the same reason that I make the
decisions all the decisions that I make
is is really trying to do my best to
serve our country and once again to
prevent more of our troops from
unnecessarily being sent into harm's way
and and look there there are important
examples of this for us to point to of
presidents who've done this in the past
Reagan and Gorbachev for example you
have JFK and Khrushchev you know you've
got Nixon going to China
meeting with Mao people going in meeting
with people who responsible for the
deaths of tens of thousands if not
millions of people but why did they have
the courage to do that because it wasn't
politically popular at the time but they
had the courage to do that because they
were looking out for the best interests
of the American people and to further
the cause of peace and safety and
security on this planet all right I have
no segue to get to these last two now
we're gonna talk about the most
important things the two final questions
and I know you've been hard out cuz you
got a Town Hall yes in town and I know
LA traffic so I want to make sure you
get there in time your workout routine
yes I just saw the video you're it's a
pretty damn good shape yeah I worked it
man I'm still in the army so I still
have like a PT test that I got a pass
and plus it just it helps you know helps
clear the mind and helps me sleep better
at night and it's just I I think it's
important to be of-of good physical and
mental fitness yeah and then okay just
one more this is the question that all
of the internet needs the answer to and
I think as someone from Hawaii you
should have
particular insight into this okay
pineapple on pizza oh geez I like it
whole thing now I know I like it I like
it
but here's the misnomer is that just
because we grow the most beautiful sweet
pineapples in Hawaii pineapple on pizza
is not a Hawaiian thing like I know it's
a vert like you got Domino's like
everyone's like Oh Hawaiian pizza like
we love our pie on my mind right now but
to my knowledge this did not originate
in Hawaii we eat pineapples in a
different way there trust me
are you grilling what are you doing yeah
actually yeah you can grilled pineapples
are beautiful you just eat them fresh
and that's the best way yeah all right
well it's been a pleasure talking
oh no they're giving us more time like
oh they're giving us a little tour do
not mean by your workout that's what I
want to know my workout is not as
impressive as you can I ask you how old
you are
I'm 38 you're 38 so I'm 43 so I got five
years out of you but I was I was
watching your workout as a and she moves
well I've got something going on with my
shoulder right now and I need to I need
to I do a lot of cardio now because my
shoulders been bothering me have been
lifting that much it's um I grew up
doing martial arts and surfing a lot so
I've always just been I've you know
loved being physically active but I
posted a couple of these videos and
people have been asking for more yeah
posting comments like oh my god I just
say three donuts no I think I better get
off my butt and go to the gym but yeah
just I think I think it is is again we
talk about health care and we should be
pushing like preventive health measures
that we can take just so we can be
healthier people is that the fun part of
this like there's such craziness and you
know you're fighting you know your own
party in a certain way to get acting to
the debates and the rest of it but the
fun part that you're posting video is
working out and like that's what catches
on people you know yeah I I don't know
there's there's a lot that's fun
actually that I really appreciate about
going on this campaign and being able to
travel to different parts of the country
seeing and learning about you know we
were at this sweet corn Fair and
festival in Adel Iowa and it's such a
cool thing because we walked in this
parade
and this farmer there in a Dell he grows
an entire acre of corn every year so
that he can give it away for free at the
a Dell sweet corn festival huh and he
built this massive corn steamer and this
whole contraption himself so that he
could steam you know thousands and
thousands ears of corn it's just it's a
huge deal in that community and it's so
much fun to be able to go and to hang
out with them to eat their sweet corn
with them and and just to be reminded
again of like we live in a really great
country with amazing people who have so
much love for each other and for our
country and and that's where I remain
inspired about the bright future that we
have before us that's that's why people
do have to get out and travel because I
think one of the reasons that I'm
hopeful despite the amount of time I
spend on in the online world where it's
just you know yeah constant I know is
that when I'm traveling and wherever I
go it's like everyone that I meet is
friendly yeah nice have you even had any
really negative experiences on the
campaign not super negative I mean again
that there's a lot of like toxic poison
that comes out on online but you know
probably the worst thing I've gotten is
is walking down a parade route for the
fourth of July and the guy with the
Mogga hat on giving me a thumbs down as
I'm walking by like yeah I told him I
was like Aloha brother yeah like it's
cool man the word sounds not I'm not
worried about that
yeah that's not what's gonna get ya
let's just jump back to the to that
incident with with Kamala were you were
you setting up for that no no I mean you
know I was obviously aware of the
different issues criminal justice reform
is something that I've been working on
throughout my time in Congress and I
feel really strongly about and you know
it's it's something that that she talks
about being very proud of her record as
Attorney General and you know the role
that she had his prosecutor for San
Francisco and I felt it was important
that she speak about how she is proud of
the record that has really inflicted
such harm on people and actually
undermined the kinds of changes that we
need to see in our criminal justice
system you know she's because it's
because it speaks to the whole
underpinning of her campaign she's ready
to be prosecutor prosecutor president a
prosecutor for the people and she was
actually the prosecutor for California
the decisions that she made actually
ended up hurting people so what would
you do for the the nonviolent drug
offenders better in jail now I think we
need to expunge their records and to
send them home I think they're they're
in jail because of a failed war on drugs
and we've got to recognize now how many
generations have gone by who have fallen
victim to this failed war on drugs I've
got the only bipartisan bill in Congress
to end the marijuana prohibition and we
had a whole group of people who came out
when we held the press conference to
announce the introduction of this bill
and one of them you know there were
veterans there who were talking about
how folks coming back from multiple
combat deployments dealing with chronic
pain dealing with post-traumatic stress
traumatic brain injury coming back to
the VA only to be told well look your
only option is oxycontin or highly
addictive opioids and federally prohibit
being federally prohibited from even
giving them a referral in a state where
medicinal marijuana is legal to go to a
dispensary they can't even do that
right because that's all run by the Fed
where it's still illegal right that's
still superseded and even right exactly
and so this is you we talked about
states rights I mean this is a perfect
example of how it's over 30 states at
this point that have done some form of
legalization of marijuana whether it's
just medicinal or full recreational but
all of those dispensaries as well as the
people who go there the financial
institution is a huge problem they're
all running on a cash market because
banks are federally regulated and are
afraid of federal prosecution but that
dark cloud of prosecution the federal
level hangs over everyone who touches
any part of this and but you know
veterans are being hurt in the process
but there was a guy there we'll be
talking about criminal just
for him he was there he was what
probably about 30 early 30s and a little
over 10 years ago he was a college
student studying computer science in
Virginia and he was charged with two
marihuana violations and because of
Virginia's mandatory minimum laws he got
to back-to-back five year sentences ten
years of his life
gone yeah and he was not he took full
responsibility for his actions wasn't
trying to point fingers anybody else but
he was there just to share his story
because there are so many people with
similar stories that just show how
terrible our broken laws are and how
this is a very sensible change that we
can and should make very quickly that
will immediately have a huge impact on
people's lives can you just talk a
little bit more about generally how your
service has affected your
decision-making abilities and sort of
what it was like what you were maybe
like beforehand and how that actually
changed you what growing up in Hawaii
you know my I'm so grateful to have had
that experience and that upbringing to
be able to cruise around and go surfing
and and to grow up in such a beautiful
place my passion as a kid and growing up
was really about protecting our
environment protecting water and air and
just a special place that we call home
and you know 9/11 like for all of us has
just changed everything and I was
serving in the state legislature in
Hawaii at the time our Brigade Combat
Team was activated for a deployment to
Iraq which is the first deployment for
our unit since Vietnam really so most
folks had not seen any kind of combat
even for those who'd serve for a very
long time my name was not on the
mandatory deployment roster when that
came out and I called my commander I
said hey what's going on I don't see my
name on the list here and he said hey
good news
you get to stay home you get to stay in
the state house you know you can be here
when we all come home and I just I knew
that there was no way that I could stay
back you know I had
a nice little office and a nice little
life and and all this stuff and I just
knew there was no way I could wave
goodbye to them my brothers and sisters
from my unit not knowing if they would
all come home so I stepped down from my
reelection campaign at the time
volunteered to deploy I got training in
a job that they needed in the field
medical unit and embarked on that
deployment is 18 months long 12 about 12
of which we spent in Iraq is an
experience that changed my life
completely where every single day I was
confronted with the high the terribly
high human cost of war never forget the
first soldier from our unit who was
killed in action and the the small
gathering that we had there in in the
desert to pay tribute to his life and
never forget those who who didn't come
home with us and coming back from both
of those deployments really fueled me
with a couple of things I knew that I
couldn't go back to the life that I had
left behind that I knew so much more
that I understood so much more both
about the cost of war about the
detrimental and devastating cost of our
failed foreign policy of these regime
change wars yes
on our troops yes on our taxpayers with
the money that trillions that's been
wasted but also on the people in the
countries where we waged these wars you
know the lives that have been destroyed
and taken you know entire communities
gone completely destroyed and came back
wanting to be in a position where I
could make decisions to stop this trend
that we've seen for too long to make
sure that we don't continue these
wasteful Wars that don't serve the
interests of our country and that gets
to what we tell will be started out
talking about about the role that
Congress has to play you know Congress
by the Constitution is the body that
declares war because you know very well
that hasn't happened since World War two
yeah and instead you see this power grab
from the executive branch but you also
suppose you on both sides and you also
see
members of Congress who lack the
political courage and will to do their
job because they don't want to be blamed
or criticized one way or the other for
making this most important decision I
introduced legislation called the no
more presidential Wars Act that would do
exactly what it says make sure that the
the responsibilities of the executive
maintain and the and the
responsibilities that Congress has a
declare war are actually upheld what do
you actually consider yourself
politically like I know the labels are
all changing and everyone's camp all
over the place right now and maybe it
doesn't matter that much yeah but it's
like yeah after an hour with you like
you have a little bit of everything I do
think is where most people are at but do
you think there is some label or some
term that I haven't accounted as where
is one you know I mean a Democrat
independent conservative libertarian I
mean yeah but I think it point I think
it points to it where I hope we go as a
country where you have people who are
less defined by the labels or the
affiliations that they have and are more
focused on how much we have in common
and the things that we really do share
and not see these descriptions as ways
to divide us but ways that we can bring
our unique ideas together to serve our
country all right well now I'm really
gonna let you go because they're telling
me that you okay but for the people that
want to see you get back into the next
debate what can they do well I hope that
people come and support our campaign
because debate or no debate we are
pushing forward and pushing forward
strong and moving our grassroots
people-powered campaign all the way to
the convention so we're gonna continue
spending a lot of time on the road and
just reaching out to people through
every platform possible coming and doing
interviews like this social media
digital ads we're putting up yard signs
making phone calls so if folks want to
come and help us you can make a
contribution or volunteer your time
tulsi 2020 comm by the way I gotta give
you credit
because as you probably saw you know we
were gonna have Buddha Joe John and then
a HuffPo went after him in a bunch of
but I didn't see that so a bunch of them
went after him saying that he shouldn't
sit down with me and then he canceled on
me
but you know I was also I was thinking
that maybe a good play for you in the
midst of the this debate nonsense could
be that as they sort of shed the other
people they don't want or as the polls
kind of change and yang maybe disappears
or some of these other guys you guys
should just be doing these things on
YouTube at the exact same time as
they're doing it on network television
and then let's really see where the
chips fall you know because something's
shift in here yeah really something is
there there's a lot of energy and things
are moving yeah it's been a pleasure I
think coming in unless the Town Hall
tonight yeah where do you go if you
leave California back to DC early
tomorrow morning wait you're gonna do
work in DC there's nothing to do in this
there are some things to do there's a
big to do in DC all right you can follow
Tulsi at Tulsi 2020 calm